we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P this caller has a quite
frankly great suggestion about
tomorrow's charity membership Drive take
a listen
hello David sir this is Liberty calling
you from Connecticut I have a question
when you have the new member drive and
the first month
is going to be you're going to match
donations yes to charity and I don't
know the name but I know about the
charity what I would like to suggest is
if you have
either a phone or on on your site an
option for those of us who are already
members right to donate what would be
equivalent to one month membership yes
for that same purpose to be doubled and
donated we've got it okay if you were
already a member tomorrow when we do the
end of the year charity membership drive
you can get as many memberships as you
want for other people by checking the
box that says this is a gift the payment
will be donated
it will be doubled and the membership
will be given to someone on our
membership waiting list which you can
find at davidpackman.com free membership
we're doing all of it and you can you
can quite literally give the membership
to anyone you want
well it's better if you know how to
spell the person's name which I don't
know that Trump did when he started
reading those names but you can send the
membership to anyone you want or you can
just leave that blank and we'll give it
away we've got like a thousand people
waiting for memberships okay bonus show
today
we're going to talk about Mike Lee's new
obsession with Banning porn
we're going to talk about the permanent
disappearance of daily room cleanings at
hotels since the pandemic good or bad
we'll talk about it and we will talk
about American self-reported mental
health at a new low not good not good
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com get
instant access to the world's famous
bonus show